We played a tournament against each other
But we had to build our own rackets
Our budget was 30 euros
And we could use anything we found at the
hardware store
Alright so we are looking for something to
make a table tennis racket out of
Let's have a look over here
This could actually be really good for chopping
A bit too uneven
I'll go further
Okay now we're getting somewhere
No...
This could be a forehand rubber
Which doormat has the most spin on it?
Maybe this?
This is quite a smooth surface
I'll take this!
Oh this is good
This one and then...
I think it will do well!
And then I just need some kind of surface
Like a rubber
This is 18 euros so far
Yes now we are talking!
The Thor's hammer!
How much is that?
12.45€
I need to put something on these sides also
Oh yes
Good sound!
I think this might work
Sheet of stainless steel
Oh this is pine
You know that's gonna be a good feeling
I'll go with this one!
This is a long pimple
This is made for me!
Let's go with this!
Okay so a successful shopping tour
Let's go build them!
Okay
I'm supposed to turn this
Into a table tennis blade
Yeah, there we go!
Okay
Is my hat full of it?
Yeah should be fine
Voila!
I think I'll do this
It looks pretty good
Okay let's see how this works
Okay
Let's get some bolts
There we go
I was thinking about some kind of easier glue
but...
Oh well, it's the same for everybody
Well, I don't really know what to say about
this!
So the rubbers
Let's see
It actually looks like a table tennis rubber!
Something like that
Perfect!
This will be so good
Forehand side
Backhand side
I think I just approach it like a normal table
tennis racket
This is... is this the only glue we've got?
Yes!
On it goes!
This is some monster glue
Years of experience gluing table tennis rubbers
finally pays off!
Well, this is my racket
It looks quite good
This is gonna be so cool to try it out!
Chop, chop, chop and smash!
Victory!
So yeah guys
We are done
So let's head inside!
Are you ready?
The big reveal
What?
Is it stuck on with nails?
Yeah it is
A really interesting design!
I've also used a carpet
Oh this is huge!
That's like a normal table tennis racket
It's like a hammer!
You guys ready for this?
Yea
What?
Okay, that's a hammer!
Okay Otto I didn't expect this at all!
We haven't tested these at all
The first touch has to be in the match
What is this shape?
Who starts?
One, two, three!
Okay so me and Miikka
So match to five points
Umm that one!
0-0!
Let the match begin!
It's surprisingly fast
Come on!
This one's really slow!
This one's the slow side
and this one's the
fast side
Sorry, sorry!
Yes!
Always hitting it too high up
It's so weird sounds with these
Yea, it's like a...
And Otto's like a cow bell
Second point!
Yes!
Forehand loop!
No!
Nice rally guys!
This is good!
This is good feeling!
So next match Otto against Emil
It feels so weird to take like a...
Yeah, this is my racket!
Tetris racket!
That one
Okay I'll start
Okay 0-0!
Oh it's so slow!
2-0
No!
This isn't working at all!
Emil you gotta change tactic or something
Yes!
That's the comeback!
This forehand side isn't that good, it really
isn't
Okay one more
A bit risky shot
It's risky for me!
Sorry
Good match
No, it wasn't!
Yea it was!
I'm happy with that result
But now at least I have some some feeling
So maybe I'll do well against Miikka
We'll see!
Nothing is lost!
If I beat Mikka then we're even
Yes!
So many edge shots
Come on!
That was a good chop from behind
Come on Emil!
You can beat him!
Thanks for the support!
If Emil wins this then Otto's got a chance
Yes!
No!
Come on!
Where did that go?
I feel a little cracking
Match point!
YES!
Ooh that was good!
Congrats for the winner!
Miikka is the DIY master
This was really fun
It was cool to make these
And see the other person's results
Exactly
And guys if you haven't noticed yet
We have a Christmas campaign going on
Where every single order including a Pongfinity net
Will come with a Christmas card signed by
all three of us!
So go and get your Christmas present from
pongfinity.store
Before the campaign ends!
Until next time!